hi guys sci-fi recapped here welcome
back to the black mirror series recap
before we start morning
spoilers ahead
today i'm going to explain a drama
science fiction series from black mirror
seasons one called the entire history of
you this episode has an unpredictable
plot twist and i think this is one of
the saddest episodes from the series
watch it till the end to find out
in the future most people will have a
device called grain implemented behind
their ear which can record everything
they see do and hear
the device has the main function called
redo which allows memories to be
replayed either in front of the user's
eyes or on a screen
the movie begins with a young lawyer
liam foxwell who is attending a work
appraisal at a law firm
after several conversations he is
required by the employers to conduct an
exhaustive redo next week liam suggests
that he is willing to do that now but
they insist to do that next week which
makes liam think that the appraisal
didn't go well and leaves the office
with an unpleasant feeling after leaving
the office liam replaces memory of it
and dwells on a seemingly insincere
phrase used by his employers
thanks to the grain technology all
passengers at the airport are now
required to perform a redo to ensure
they have not been doing something
suspicious in the previous day or week
liam then arrives at a dinner party
arranged by his wife's friend and
welcomed by lucy upon entering he sees
his wife theon is talking to a man he
does not remember whom later she
introduces as jonas
jeff who turns out to be working on
recruitment asks liam about his
appraisal and suggests we do it on a big
screen so that they can give their
opinions on it but jones suddenly comes
and saves liam from the embarrassment
at dinner jonas shares stories about his
personal life
one of them is about how often he
pleases himself with the red dos from
his earlier relationship
throughout the meal then becomes
suspicious of how fondly phi seems to be
looking at jonas he also becomes very
jealous of him as fi always laughs at
jonah's cheap jokes
one of them hallum claims that her grain
was gouged about a year ago for some
perverts and says she was lucky because
it didn't break her vision
when liam and phi return home the couple
is looking at their babies redo when
liam suddenly brings up a topic about
jonas again
he then discovers that phi had had a
relationship with jonas many years ago
which she had mentioned to liam before
but downplayed liam finds it hilarious
because he sees jonas as a silly person
still having doubts about it liam
replays their conversation about jonas
and phi says that their relationship
just lasted for a week
after arguing with each other phi
eventually admits that their
relationship lasted for six months out
of control liam insults her as a b and
phi becomes very upset
before sleep liam apologizes to his wife
and they replay a recording of them
having intercourse together these lies
make liam more paranoid and he insists
on replaying footage from the previous
evening he even asked their babysitter
gina opinion whether the cheap jokes
from jonas were funny or not whilst
drinking excessively
filled with jealousy liam also questions
phi about her expression while looking
at jonas accusing her of still having
feelings for jonas phi becomes
increasingly uncomfortable with his
relentless questioning and their
relationship becomes worse and worse
phi then walks away and liam continues
his drinking
a few moments later liam drunkenly
drives towards jonah's house to ask for
an explanation
upon arrival he breaks into jonah's
house and starts talking nonsense he
even insults jonas in front of his
girlfriend
the couple politely ask liam to leave
but instead he attacks jonas and forces
jonas to show all the recordings on a tv
screen
he also threatens to cut his neck and
gouge the grain if jonas does not delete
all the footage of phi
jonas complies and liam drives away
crashing his car into a tree
liam then walks home and confronts phi
who is still sleeping
liam randomly questions his wife whether
she and jonas were using condom while
having intercourse and asks if the baby
is his daughter
liam also mentions how he hates the
picture hanging in their bedroom which
makes phi confused
it turns out that liam noticed that
there was a file proving that jonas infy
had sex in their bedroom 18 months ago
around the time their daughter was
conceived
fiven admits that she cheated on liam
saying that it was when liam walked out
from their home for five days
phi also insists that they were using
condom at that time and says that liam
is the baby's father
liam demands phy to replay the redo of
it to prove her words but she lies that
the recording has been deleted
liam is not fooled and forces fi to show
the recording on the screen
fight complies
the video heavily implies that they were
not using a condom while having fun
at the end of the movie liam is seen
wandering around his now empty house
playing ritos of his happy memories with
phi and his daughter
desperate and hopeless he goes to the
bathroom and starts cutting the grain
out of his neck with a razor blade
do you think that this is the saddest
episode compared to other black mirror
series episodes
share your thoughts in the comment
section below
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching